assassin's creed has long experimented
with its protagonists having magic-like
abilities oftentimes explored in
post-launch expansions dawn of ragnarok
is the latest adding to assassin's creed
valhalla by pivoting from avor to delve
into the story of javi the acer who is
most well known as odin
dawn of ragnarok doesn't quite reach the
highs found in assassin's creed's
previous myth and legends focused
expansions falling short in both
delivering a compelling narrative and
fully embracing its initial open-ended
gameplay loop however donna ragnarok
does satisfyingly evolve valhalla's
combat and navigation via rewarding
assortment of cool mythical powers
in donna ragnarok javi travels to the
realm of the dwarves to save his son
from suter the flaming isu warlord of
muspelheim sorcerer has invaded with an
army composed of giants from both the
icy ottenheim and fiery moose behind for
some unknown purpose though javi has no
interest in learning what that purpose
is he still finds himself aiding the
besieged dwarves in order to gather the
necessary support to save his son listen
harvey
i understand
this isn't your war
you just want your son back but those
spells on our doorstep
they ain't no joke
if they find us
we're dead meat the campaign attempts to
navigate the complexities of javi's
abusive nature so far we've only seen a
self-proclaimed god who's so
self-assured that he can't find fault in
any of his actions reasoning that his
mistreatment of his allies is a
necessary evil for bettering asgard and
ensuring his own survival for all time
even through the events of ragnarok and
his predetermined demise don of ragnarok
sees javi come face to face with this
aspect of himself and the isu is
regularly presented with examples of how
the ends don't always justify the means
it's an intriguing hook but not one that
gets a satisfying payoff his story just
sort of ends instead the final moments
of the expansion explore evor positing
that the viking learns a lesson that
javi could not and that would be an
interesting development if valhalla's
base campaign hadn't already concluded
with a similar finale so in the end dawn
of ragnarok's campaign feels a lot like
the stories told in wrath of the druids
and the siege of paris and that it
doesn't explore narrative concepts
beyond what's already touched upon in
valhalla it instead retreads old ground
and feels a bit samey as a result in
terms of gameplay however don of
ragnarok introduces several new ideas
for valhalla's formula transforming how
you're able to navigate its world and
fight enemies within it early into his
journey javi is gifted the hygge rip a
gauntlet that allows him to rip the
hooger the mind and emotions of a
creature's soul from dead enemies and
animals and inherit their forms and
abilities each of the powers supports
one of assassin's creed's core tenets
parkour combat and social stealth
creating engaging opportunities to
experiment with how javi can tackle a
problem
thanks hobby i knew you wouldn't let us
down
javi plays a lot like assassin's creed
odyssey's cassandra incorporating a
combination of standard movements and
god-like powers if you're willing to
engage with both move sets and carefully
consider how to use each to your
advantage you can tear through
encampments with an enjoyable ease and a
fulfilling display of strength javi can
only hold onto two huger at a time and
each ability needs to be charged before
it can be used encouraging you to be
strategic in both what you choose to
have access to and when you decide to
utilize it this additional consideration
can lead to moments of rewarding
adaptation but it too easily limits the
experience it's annoying to get to
points in the story where you need a
certain power to proceed but you don't
have it equipped forcing you to
backtrack and find an enemy with the
hooker you need it fortunately doesn't
happen too often but it occurs just
enough to be noticeably irritating the
hygge rip isn't the only big change the
town of ragnarok implements the
expansion opts for a more open-ended
approach to exploration in comparison to
previous assassin's creed games after a
prologue javi emerges from a cave to
find himself a tafa cliff presenting the
player with a breathtaking view of
towering mountains green valleys and
rolling hills the game provides no
waypoint at this moment only loose
directions to find a way to save javi's
son and if time allows discover the
hidden hideaways of the dwarves and aid
them in their fight against suitor that
moment emulates a scene that's become
increasingly familiar in games in the
years following the release of 2017's
the legend of zelda breath of the wild
dawn of ragnarok does initially embody
those clear inspirations kicking off
with a hands-off open world structure
you do get waypoints for your next
mission once you discover a new
narrative thread but completing that
thread leaves you once again devoid of
any waypoint to chase after and so in
donna ragnarok's early hours progression
is solely tied to your freedom to
explore and discover a first for an
assassin's creed game it's refreshingly
novel for the series and there are a few
interesting things to find in those
early hours to keep you excited as what
may hide beyond the next hill however
don of ragnarok reverts to assassin's
creed's traditional structure about
midway through once the story gets going
the expansion starts regularly supplying
you with waypoints including to
locations you may not have had the
pleasure of discovering on your own yet
this keeps the story of the campaign
moving at a nice brisk pace but it
undermines the sense of wonder and
exploration the expansion cultivates in
its early hours and once that happens
the map becomes a place of
interconnected destinations not a space
to explore by the time i finished dawn
of ragnarok i was playing the game by
climbing on my mount telling it to
follow the road to the next waypoint and
pulling up my phone to do a quick social
media doom scroll while waiting for javi
to reach his destination on his own
that's a typical approach for getting
around valhalla but a disappointing
development given the initial promise of
freedom the dawn of ragnarok's early
hours provided dawn of ragnarok is
almost transformative for assassin's
creed teasing the possibility of what
the series could become without the
overt hand-holding that has defined it
for almost two decades however after an
intriguing opening donna ragnarok falls
back on old habits and that feeling
coupled with how the expansion's
narrative themes feel too similar to the
base game creates an experience that too
often resembles something we've already
had before but donna ragnarok is built
on the bones of a great action-adventure
rpg and that carries much of the
expansion especially with the rewarding
considerations introduced with the hygge
rip only time will tell if avor and
hobby's story continues beyond donna
ragnarok but if this is the end it's a
fine enough conclusion to the
relationship between the two
[Music]
let's stretch them
huh